the latest CBS News battleground tracker
of Democratic presidential candidates
focuses on Super Tuesday that's a key
day in the race Democratic voters in the
fourteen states holding primaries on
March 3rd same favored brother former
Vice President Joe Biden followed
closely by senators who lives Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders now the poll
also shows a newcomer to the race that's
former New York City Mayor Mike
Bloomberg he's in fifth place with four
percent support Ed O'Keefe is covering
the campaign 2020 so ed what do these
numbers tell us well good morning Gail
the new poll shows that the Democratic
race is still pretty fluid and that has
voters nervous for in 10 Democratic
voters in the 14 states holding
primaries on Super Tuesday March 3rd say
they're uneasy about whether any
Democratic candidate can defeat
President Trump but Bloomberg strategy
might be paying off former New York
Mayor Michael Bloomberg opened his first
campaign field office on Sunday not in
Iowa or New Hampshire but in the Super
Tuesday state of North Carolina we're
here and we are gonna stay here not just
through Super Tuesday but through the
Republican convention when you-know-who
comes to town less than a month on the
campaign trail Bloomberg is already on
track to be spending more than one
hundred million dollars on TV ads and
jobs Grieder leader problem-solver a new
CBS News poll finds that Bloomberg is
pulling support away from former Vice
President Joe Biden but about half of
Democratic voters in particular backers
of Senators Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders believe Bloomberg's campaign
shows the rich could have too much
influence in politics I'm talking a
clear distinction between myself
meanwhile nine Democratic contenders
signed a letter over the weekend asking
party leaders to change the rules that
determine who gets to appear at the
Bates they argue the current rules which
require both a polling and fundraising
threshold have unnecessarily and
artificially narrowed the strongest and
most diverse Democratic field in history
the letter was started by Senator Cory
Booker who didn't make the stage for
this week's debate and has been raising
concerns for
it is a problem that we now have a
overall campaign for the 2020 presidency
that has more billionaires in it than
black people the DNC is unlikely to
change the rules for January's debate
but party leaders say they might
consider changes for debates scheduled
in February and March 7 candidates are
set to debate on Thursday in Los Angeles
five of them are men six of them are
white there is a chance however there
won't be a debate a labor dispute
ongoing between food service workers at
the Loyola Marymount University in Los
Angeles where the debate is going to be
held and the company that employs them
could force a picket line the candidates
say they won't cross a picket line
Anthony if one goes up before Thursday
right we'll see yeah thank you very much